These four types of competition may
seem like a lot, and they can be.
But you don't need to focus
on all of them at once.
It's just really to help
you organize your thoughts.
Now with our flavored water example,
if you're a brand manager of this water
bottle, you'll need to analyze
all four levels of competition so
you know how to position yourselves
in terms of the brand and
in terms of real placement of
this product on store shelves.
But as a startup with an app,
it's good to know the different types of
competition you have out there, at
the different levels, but don't bother
over-analyzing the competition at levels
that make less sense for you right now.
Like the budget level.
So now that we know the different
types of competition,
how do we figure out
where we fit among them?
Well, let's talk about that now.